j'accueille maintenant notre chose
analystes et de la soirée edouard
balladur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lancé le 1er mai me seban soir
bon toi merci de merci de venir dans
tout le monde en parle
c'est un peu
comme en ce moment ça nous rajeunit
voila voila merci en tous les cas d'être
d'être venu ce soir reconnaissait roger
hanin alors vous avez en commun avec
roger hanin le fait d'être pas très
jospiniste vous parce que vous pensez
que la politique de jospin c'est pas
celle qu'il faudrait faire et roger
hanin lui communiste roger hanin donc
vous n'êtes pas jospiniste par
définition non mais en tout cas moi je
vous demande et je ne me fait pas parler
de jose pas pourquoi parce que je ne
veux pas
voilà c'est sec ça équivaut à une
profession de foi et je n'ai pas une
obsession je veux pas ses ennemis en
fonds de commerce une obsession tout le
monde connaît mon opinion là dessus je
les dis souvent ça suffit voilà ouais on
m'avait dit que c'est un homme
méprisable acquis d'une serviette à
paris c'était j'ai passé un bon ou
mauvais journalistes non stocks restait
pas bonnes à des journalistes qui disent
qu'ils ont envie de dire c'est des bons
journalistes ben oui c'est alors et
c'est ce qu'ils ne disent pas non mais
c'est vrai que jospin avait dit je mange
explique pour nos amis téléspectateurs
vous n'êtes pas obligé de répondre
lionel jospin avait dit en parlant de
françois mitterrand donc le beau frère
de roger hanin j'aurais préféré qu'il a
un passé plus net il faut faire un
inventaire et tourner la page ce à quoi
roger hanin a répondu problème c'est que
jospin il était sur la page bon et vous
ne répondez pas et
vous avez dit c'était un homme
méprisable qui serait pas la main voilà
ceci étant chaque âme à vous dire une
chose je vous demande pas répondre mais
je sais pas un jospin sérieusement il a
reconnu la responsabilité de la france
dans la tragédie des juifs pendant la
guerre ce que mitterrand n'avait pas
fait oui mais je pense qu'il a eu raison
voilà je suis juif le presse de le
préciser je pense que c'est un nombre
d'états qui n'a pas agir un graff et je
sais par la famine et je vais vous dire
moi j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour pour
jacques chirac d'autant plus qu'à la
mort de françois mitterrand c'était un
des un homme politique a une attitude du
magnifique alors d'autres n'ont fait
qu'en tant dans leur médiocre différence
est là chirac était magnifique je ne
l'oublierai jamais voilà bon alors voilà
donc je voulais dire ça on peut dire
aussi mais encore une fois vous n'êtes
pas obligé de répondre que jospin il n'a
jamais eu la francisque il a jamais été
amis avec bousquet oui là je vais vous
répondre que l'histoire de 2,2 de
l'amitié de bousquet c'est une vraiment
un procès en sorcellerie je vais vous
dire pourquoi recettes pas par
affirmation moi je connais françois
mitterrand depuis 42 ans par le présent
et je veux dire je connais tous ses amis
peu ou prou vous décollez mieux je
connais moins bien vous les connaît tous
je n'ai jamais vu dans ma vie croisées
aperçu rené bousquet alors je ne dis pas
qu'il ne l'ait pas vu mais je veux dire
que ça peut pas être en grand à jouer
lorsqu'il a vu il l'a vu d'après les
dires de françois huit fois en 40 ans
moi je veux dire un ami je ne vois pas
huit fois en quarante ans va d'autre
part qui serait très intéressant parce
qu'on s'arrête toujours vous avez pas
pardon de de tenir longtemps
17,2 intéressant merci je dis que
je dis que sont les grands journalistes
d'investigation
ils n'ont pas eu la curiosité de savoir
pourquoi pourquoi on a innocenté blanchi
rendu toutes ses décorations tous ces
titres à rené bousquet ça n'intéresse
personne ça c'est très très intéressant
de savoir pourquoi on a été innocenté
dit un peu aux journalistes lisant leur
dis là vous aviez sûrement des réseaux
voix et sûrement des réseaux nous en
train de leur dire voilà si les écoute
ils devraient les deux mains vous savez
maintenant en branle jean edouard
balladur monsieur le premier ministre
vous plaît monsieur le ministre vous
appelez douala dire beaucoup
vous le savez pouvoir pourquoi bousquet
a été on lui a rendu ses décorations et
tout ça je ne sais pas je crois qu'il
est passé en jugement après la guerre
je ne sus ne sait pas bien s'il a été
condamné à quelle durée de condamnation
relativement bref je dois où il a repris
une activité professionnelle je pense
qu'il s'est passé il a été condamné
d'abord ah oui c'est ça c'est ce que les
centaines d attente deuxième à une
deuxième examen bah on va enquêter
edouard balladur donc vous la mairie de
paris vous avez proposé une réunion
passé la soirée là dessus mais juste le
sentiment réfère retient vous a proposé
une réunion des patrons de la droite
c'est-à-dire berrou pour l'udf pasqua
pour le rpf madelin pour eux des ailes
et mam michèle alliot marie pour le rpr
sérieusement on parle beaucoup de vous
comme candidat possible pour paris est
ce que c'est
c'est quoi je passais milan l'air c'est
une idée en l'air ou c'est vous y croyez
vous avez envie écoutez j'ai la
situation est compliquée ça vous a pas
échappé oui ça c'est bien il ya un
multiplicité il ya panafieu jeun pas ya
tiberi à ce gain il ya dominati c'est
vrai qu'il ya pas mal de candidats et
pas envie de la compliquer encore
davantage que les dirigeants des partis
concernés se réunissent qu'ils arrêtent
une façon de procéder et qu'ils prennent
des décisions moi je soutiendrai celui
qu'ils choisiront je peux pas dire mieux
alors voilà c'est cool
c'est trop je
suis fier que la cravate oui il est en
train de parler d'un sujet reste
compétir et sur ce que va faire ses jeux
et écrire deux trois trucs les mots clés
pour comprendre d'accord d'accord très
bien mais c est
ce que l on met ça va mais c'est parce
que tout est compris oui tout et tout
est clair
plus sérieusement et sur un plan plus
général maintenant maintenant que que la
gauche finalement est devenu libéral
qu'est ce que la droite peut faire est
ce que la gauche est devenu libéral
déjà plus libérale qu avant d en
reliques strauss kahn c'est un peu
sociale libérale oui m'enfin n est plus
là une arme à se taire et faire un peu
la même politique enfin moi je vais vous
dire ce que je pense grosso modo quelles
différences ou qu'elle devrait elle être
qu'elle devrait l'être
la gauche croit davantage au pouvoir de
l'état pour organiser une société plus
juste grosso modo distribuer dix ans
pour organiser une société plus juste
grosso modo c'est ça la gauche pas si
roger un homme contraria quant à dire ah
je vois que c'est ça la droite elle dit
pas qu'il faut pas d'état mais elle dit
que la liberté c'est plus efficace et
plus dynamique on peut en discuter à
perte de vue bon on prend quelques
exemples
les 35 heures obligatoires moi je suis
pour les 35 heures ouais c'est
l'évolution normale des choses et puis
même un jour - sans doute mais le
problème c'est de savoir si ça doit être
obligatoire automatique pour tout le
monde et là c'est un vrai critère de
distinction entre la droite et la gauche
depuis des dizaines d'années la durée du
travail a diminué en france je dirais
naturellement progressivement
alors est-ce qu'il faut prendre une loi
autoritaire qui dit tout le monde doit
travailler quatre heures de moins dans
la semaine je crois que c'est un des
vrais critères d'une nation n'y a pas
une grande différence sur les 35 heures
vous êtes d'accord vous dites simplement
il faut pas que ça soit obligatoire
c'est une fameuse différents oui là bas
non ce qui serait une vraie différence
si vous soyez contre les 35 heures par
exemple ah bah oui mais ça ce serait
absurde parce que l'évolution normale
des choses c'est la diminution de la
durée du travail je ne suis pas d'accord
je déconne alors l'économie et à ses
forêts car on voit bien on a vu les
résultats avec un ami fait c'est
l'euphorie pourtant les riches sont les
régions les riches en plus en plus
riches et les pauvres de de plus en plus
pauvres est ce que le le marché en train
de devenir finalement le le
totalitarisme du siècle qui commence et
se voit et c'est une idée très répandue
par quoi est ce qu'il faut le remplacer
du passé on a essayé non mais on a
essayé en dire le marché c'est injuste
il ya une part d'injustice d'ailleurs
c'est tout à fait vrai
qui va répartir la richesse répartir le
travail
répartir les profits du travail
ça c'est pas être là ça peut être que le
marché mais mais mais il faut que tout
ça soit organisé pour qu'ils aient plus
de justice regardez à seattle par
exemple il ya eu tout un grande
agitation contre la liberté du commerce
dans le monde parfait
moi je suis pas pour une liberté sauvage
et complète un je m'empresse de le dire
au contraire mais qu'est ce que je
constate c'est que cette organisation
mondiale du commerce est la seule chance
connaît d'organiser des choses est que
si on l'affaiblît ce sera l'anarchie
c'est à dire que pour le coup les pays
riches gagneront de plus en plus
d'argent et les pays pauvres
s'appauvriront 116 avantage donc on a
besoin d'organiser les choses
c'est pourquoi moi je suis libéral
plutôt libérale libéral mais je pense
que l'état a un rôle comme organisateur
de la règle ultra libéral a pas du tout
non absolument pas pour intervenir à
angers si vous gabon à vis de la
différence le groupe a beaucoup pour le
moment entre la gauche et la droite donc
jamais at il n'y a pas beaucoup de
différence c'est vrai que les pauvres
entre pauvres mais ça va beaucoup plus
loin c'est à dire que c'est ce sont les
dépenses d'un état qui fecteau coup il
ya plus de richesses vous avez aussi
dure et bobby de 2-2-2 de la réussite de
l'allemagne après la guerre mais il y
avait une raison c'est qu'il n'avait pas
de budget de la guerre pas de budget de
la défense c'était des milliards qui
rentrait dans une économie qu'on dirait
de vie si je vous dis aujourd'hui si un
pays décide de faire un sixième ou
septième sous marin toby qui coûtent des
milliards ou de ne pas le faire cet
argent irait ailleurs ce sont des vrais
choix n'est pas la cas pas tout à fait
parce que nos buts dépenses unitaire
site ait nos dépenses militaires sont
pas très importants beaucoup moins
importante que celle des américains
c'est des runes des raisons et roger
hanin le sait aussi bien que moi de la
faiblesse les pays européens d'aidé
qu'ils ont quelque chose à faire ils
sont obligés d'aller chercher des
américains pour les aider ils n'ont pas
les avions qui font ou n'ont pas les
moyens de transport qu'il faut et moi je
les ai vécus notamment dans une série
d'opérations qu'on a dû faire ou qu'on
n'a pas pu faire parce qu'on n'avait pas
de moyens bien alors edouard balladur
est ce que vous connaissez la taxe tobin
été inventée jeudi pour nos amis donc
été inventé par un économiste américain
qui est prix nobel d'économie et la taxe
tobin ça consiste à taxer à 0,1 pour
cent toutes les transactions sur le
marché des changes et ça rapporterait
chaque année la setac cela rapporterait
228 milliards de dollars ce qui
permettrait d rast et ça permettrait
d'éradiquer une bonne part de la
pauvreté est-ce que vous donc ça
permettrait aux séquelles quand même
dans le monde il faut le savoir un
milliard sept d'humains qui ont moins
d'un dollar par jour sert moins de 5
francs par jour donc cette taxe
permettrait que ces gens là évidemment
est beaucoup plus d'argent est ce que
vous vous seriez prêt à militer pour que
la france inscrive
d'abord le parlement
oui je vais vous dire
j'ai été ministre des finances oui
justement c'est pour ça que c'est toute
l'administration des finances étaient
contre et pourquoi pas sous prétexte que
c'est pas applicable si tout le monde
n'applique pas c'est applicable je suis
d'accord mais moi du cje surprendre les
spécialistes je suis plutôt pour a et je
vais vous dire pourquoi et je vais vous
dire pourquoi c'est pas tellement
parce que maintenant on a milité pour ça
et on va voir tous les gens qui disaient
pas tellement nous aider c'est pas
tellement pour redistribuer de l'argent
ceci ça aide bien sûr c'est bien mais il
y à chaque jour
1500 milliards de dollar qui s'échange
sur les marchés financiers du monde 1500
milliards de dollars tous les jours et
pour des bus qui pour la plus grande
partie sont des but spéculatif ya il
faut jeu passant ou de son milliard de
dollars pour les besoins du commerce et
de l'investissement elle reste la
spéculation on a des machines
automatiques qui virent d'un marché à
l'autre pour gagner un quart de point
100 millions de dollars ces virées
automatiquement bon donc l'idée de la
taxe tobin c'est de dire il faut que ça
coûte quand même un peu d'argent de
spéculer
vous devez veiller sans payer quelque
chose et moi je suis pour alors on me
dit oui mais il ya des paradis fiscaux
il ya des pays qui l'appliqueront pas
ben je vais vous dire alors une autre de
mes convictions je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que j'étais pour le marché
projet n'en était plus réservé que je ne
suis mais soyons précis si on veut un
marché mondial si on veut la
mondialisation il faut une loi
internationale voilà et un pouvoir qui
la fasse appliquer et si on a rit on y
arrive je vous assure que bien des maux
de notre société pourront disparaître
alors à partir de là si ça rapporte de
l'argent qu'on l'affecté aux
investissements dans les pays les plus
pauvres gens suis mille fois d'accord
mais je crois qu'il ya toutes les
technocrates et la technostructure chaud
parce qu'on dit et les finances de tous
les pays il dit évolué qui sont
réticents et moi je pense qu'on est
beaucoup trop conservateurs ont bien
écouté je suis heureux de vous entendre
dire ça en tous les cas la france
s'enorgueillit d'être le premier pays à
elle a signé 7 signés ce projet plus
impliqué seul on ne peut pas l'appliquer
seulement facile déjà la france commence
à dire voilà nous on va le faire
peut-être qu'après l'angleterre le fera
sinon pourquoi ne peut pas l'appliquer
sonne pas parce que c'est sur une
transaction internationale toute la
journée sur le marché des changes
internationaux va taxer l'argent qui va
qui va spéculer à la france mais il y
aura plus d'argent qui viendra en france
du tout bon à l'arrière de bah oui faut
savoir ce qu'on veut et tout ça soit sur
0,1 pour cent c'est à dire que les
maires et quand vous virer de l'argent
pour gagner 0 25% et composants prend
0,10 aux passagers qui nous envahit
volant risque 0 15 vous vous dites moi
je vais aller dans un pays où il n'ya
pas la taxe tobin voilà c'est aussi
simple que ça voilà maintenant qu'elle
n'est pas quand même
beaucoup plus fort que vous moi ok donc
je donc je répète pour nos amis quel
spectateur mais c'est avoir un pour cent
de taxation sur les sur les transferts
de fonds enfin sur le marché des changes
vous savez mieux que moi ça fait donc
228 milliards de dollars par an et je
rappelle qu'il ya un milliard 7,2 gens
qui ont moins d'un dollar par jour si ça
vous intéresse vous pouvez vous adresser
à l'association attac le numéro
s'inscrit sur l'écran 01 43 36 30 54
alors edouard balladur maintenant que le
président république est élu au suffrage
universel depuis 62 compte tenu de la
puissance des médias et en particulier
évidemment de la télévision est ce que
vous croyez pas et on en vient à vous
particulièrement est ce que vous
pourriez pas que ça facilite l'élection
de deux candidats disons au look un peu
populaire voire populiste est ce que
finalement c'est pas c'est pas un
problème ça parce qu'ils étaient des
très bon président de la république
potentiel qui passe mal à la télé oui ça
peut arriver
mais enfin quand vous faites la liste
des présidents depuis le général de
gaulle
il n'avait pas les uns ou les autres un
look spécialement populiste sans que je
pense que jacques chirac en 95 il
passait mieux pour la télé par exemple
par exemple oui mais enfin non je sais
par exemple on sais pas peut-être que
vous auriez été un meilleur président
simplement tout à la télé il admet dans
la rue comme ça quand il est filmé dans
la vie je vais vous dire j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de démontrer oui
je sais pas est ce que finalement c'est
pas un problème bien sûr que c'est un
problème personnage finalement régissant
est-ce que c'est pas un problème tant
attendu au suffrage universel il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut on vit dans une
démocratie
oui un bon donc il est normal que soient
les citoyens qui choisissent bien et ben
voilà alors on peut toujours dire que ce
serait mieux si c'était autrement j'en
suis pas sûr du tout nous avons une
démocratie c'est un bon système il faut
le conserver puis voilà il a ses
contraintes
ça vous inquiète pas c'est ça qui est ça
le fait que finalement ça puisse amener
un certain populisme
au pouvoir oui mon fort coûteux c'est
pas un risque qui s'est vérifiée jusqu'à
présent se passe si on pouvait dire que
le général de gaulle était populiste il
monsieur pompignane n'a pas quand il est
venu en 58 sénat monsieur ses premières
dès que ce suffrage universel oui mon
enfant 65 il a quand même été mais
l'humain ni monsieur giscard d'estaing
et monsieur mitterrand elle n'était pas
spécialement populiste bon donc que
chirac était populaire il était
populaire wild était puisqu'il a été élu
mais voilà c'est le meilleur des
critères au fond alors je vous posais
une question vous avez mon vouloir oui
mais chaude ici je suis obligé de vous
la poser parce que quand on a j'ai eu
des conversations téléphoniques avec
votre entourage pour réparer cette
émission il mendie faut pas lui parler
de ça et moi non mais c'est pas quelque
chose de scandaleux et je le dis tout de
suite je me permettrai pas
moi je pense qu'on m'a dit il faut pas
parler à edouard balladur de ses
origines turques parce que ça va
l'énerver oui mais c'est alors je vois
pas non excusez moi je continue puis je
vous sais de la parole moi je vois pas
ce qu'il y a d'abord évidemment
de péjoratif à être d'origine turque
surtout que votre famille on peut en
parler d'eux depuis très longtemps lié à
la france puisque vous étiez d une
famille de citoyens ottomans et protégé
français protégés de deux longues de
longue date alors moi je comprends pas
parce que des fois on vous reproche
d'être hautain d'être distant et en fait
vous êtes un travailleur immigré oui si
on vous je plaisante pas
ma famille est effectivement devenue
française il ya quelques générations
puis voilà quoi c'est tout c'est comme
si votre fallu en parler de façon
générale je parle très peu de moi oui
bon j'ai pris un risque en venant chez
vous vous l'aurez par aof enfin on va
voir
vous avez été un proche collaborateur de
georges pompidou et vous avez en commun
quelque chose avec roger hanin c'est
finalement vous avez été proche de
pompidou dans les dernières années à une
époque où il était très malade et vous
vous connaissiez j'imagine la maladie du
président mitterrand et ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est que personne enfin tous
les cas l'avenir ni l'autre vous avez eu
à coeur de le dire
le savez je laisse eu quatre ou cinq ans
avant sa mort peut-être quatre ans
j'avoue je n'ai pas qui publie des
bulletins de santé disons que tout
allait bien alors que ça n'est pas bien
mais nous avons tous très bien elle est
très bien en ayant en ayant un cancer de
la prostate outre le soigne
quand françois mitterrand a été atteint
dans une santé admirable sont faits les
deux dernières années et vous la dirai
par parenthèse qu on n est jamais vu ça
doit exister des cas de courage physique
j'ai jamais vu un courage physique comme
françois mitterrand pendant les derniers
mois de sa maladie à l'époque avec le
président georges pompidou les derniers
et dernière année enfin les derniers
mois pareil est-ce que c'était pas grave
de cacher quantité racing qui je me
souviens que quand même très atteints
est ce que ce n'est pas grave de cacher
aux français l'état physique de du
présent la public est ce qu'il le
connaissait lui même je ne sais pas
moi en tout cas je ne connaissais pas
puis ça a été beaucoup plus rapide que
pour monsieur mitterrand sur et sa durée
et la
durée visible de sa maladie sa durée un
an
pour monsieur mitterrand ça a été plus
long parce que c'est toujours plus long
ce genre de maladie j'en ai d'ailleurs
parlé avec lui plusieurs fois je parle
d'eux
de françois mitterrand enfin il en a
parlé c'est pas moi qui me serais permis
de lui en parler bien entendu on va
parler de façon très libre d'ailleurs
très
j'allais dire décontracté il est
référencé la maladie du président
pompidou non non non non vous entendiez
bien avec lui sourit enfin une semble
surcroît n'a une ou deux périodes de
tension comme c'est normal
deux ans c'est quand même lui vous aimez
beaucoup eh ben c'est bien sûr est entré
ce que vous me dites aux villes à s'être
la gournerie je vous le dis non non ça
on s'est bien entendu et
j'ai respecté ses prérogatives et il m'a
laissé libre d'agir dans les domaines
qui étaient les miens donc ça s'est bien
passé très bien mais ils doivent à la
dure maintenant on va faire une
interview qui s'appelle lardy view on va
baisser la lumière il faut pas bouger
par un jingle
[Musique]
vous avez pas bougé ça méritait
imperturbable
vous pensez à quoi là en ce moment oui
bon je passe je me dire que ce qu'il va
me demander
est ce que je vous demande et c'est
qu'elle est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher
je ferme le livre que je lis tous les
soirs oui je lis de deux heures tous les
soirs nous irons en ce moment
en ce moment je lis un recueil de
nouvelles japonaise une littérature que
je connais pas du tout et un livre de
l'épousé de jean pierre elkabbach nicole
avril l'école rude sur le visage
absolument le matin qu'on voyait dans la
glace vous dites quoi
il faut absolument il faut absolument
que ce soit se battent wallet
vous en seriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique en bois oui
enfin physiquement se payer une baguette
magique vous changeriez quoi il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à changer mais c'est
pas possible y a pas de baguette magique
quelle est la phrase que vous ne
supportez pas d'entendre
c'est difficile parce que c'est l'alibi
de toutes les deux tous les renoncements
tout difficile de dire à la limite c'est
pas trop difficile là pour vous
présentement non ça va bien vous fait
plaisir je suis très inquiet que ça oui
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois
je pleure pas beaucoup ne pleure pas
beaucoup je le regrette d'ailleurs
partiel pas de déshonneur à pleurer non
non non mais enfin c'est comme ça je le
regrette parce que ça quand ça se
produit ça soulage la dernière fois
c'était pour quelqu'un de cher et que
j'ai perdu voilà qui est la dernière
personne que vous ayez envie de tuer
j'ai jamais eu envie de tuer personne
non mais je comprends pas la question
parce que pour la dernière s'impliquent
on a déjà tué quelques uns donc on a eu
envie envie envie
la dernière qu'on a eu envie que ça
c'est navarro
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus en
vous
je suis impatient
c'est un défaut j'aime que les choses
aillent vite et parfois j'ai fait trop
vite et voilà comment aimeriez-vous
mourir bas comme tout le monde vite mais
est toujours impatient mais toujours
impatients vous puisque tech qui est
terrible au fond c'est la dégradation
physique ouais c'est pas la mort encore
comme je ne suis jamais mort jusqu'à
presque huit mois
mais peut être réincarné peut-être vous
êtes un vieux incarner on ne sait pas
est ce que d'ailleurs si vous étiez
réincarner vous déjà très incarnée ans
qui en rejettent un enrico macias ou
michel boujenah
roger
attendait re sais
[Applaudissements]
pas ce que j'ai expliqué à monsieur
edouard balladur que pendant la guerre
je suis un peu plus âgés que le monsieur
balladur qu'il a il a une attitude
extraordinairement courageuse en libye
en cyrénaïque en egypte et il a été
formidable il a relevé le gant d'une
armée française qu'on pouvait un petit
peu brocardé à l'huile à dire aux jeunes
auraient pu dire michel boujenah
parce que j'étais pas là
raquin deux autres dernière question
monsieur pour les ministes dernière
question si c'était à refaire votre vie
vous referiez quoi pas pareil
dans ma vie
je voulais être médecin quand j'étais
jeune et puis j'ai été malade donc je
sais pas pu l'être donc j'ai pris
d'autres études qui était à l'époque
considéré comme plus facile
j'aurais quand même bien émettre médecin
merci beaucoup ont râlé merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux